here's a mystery who exactly wants to
see another sherlock holmes movie more
than 10 years after the last one we're
about to find out and the answer
probably won't be pretty
i agree it's not my best disguise but i
had to make do
ben affleck may be a movie star but the
days of an actor being able to put butts
in seats on the basis of their celebrity
alone are pretty much over even for the
star of geely knowing this disney's
release strategy for deep water a film
produced under its 20th century studios
brand seems to be released the movie
quietly in january and whatever happens
happens in the film affleck plays a
wealthy husband hoping to stay far away
from a pricey divorce by letting his
wife played by anna de armas have
extramarital affairs but he becomes
suspect number one when one of her
paramours suddenly vanishes the movie
comes out on january 14th and as of the
making of this video there's not a
trailer or even a poster for it yet with
zero hype for the movie so far deep
water seems to be in deep well you know
betting against marvel is like betting
against the harlem globetrotters just
because marvel boasts earth's mightiest
heroes that doesn't mean the brand is
invincible especially when it's not
marvel studios but sony's marvel
affiliated spider-man spin-off series
confused
it's hard to tell where sony's morbius
falls in the canon we think it's a
spin-off of tom hardy's venom series
with nothing to do with the marvel
cinematic universe but these days who
can tell
i
am venom
what we do know is that thanks to lots
of delays and bad buzz the anticipation
for this movie is colder than its
january release date where sony is
sending it to die a quiet undeath you
may be saying so what people said the
same thing about venom but venom was one
of the 90s most popular comic book
villains and morbius has always been
dealest or lower it's possible that
morbius will surprise everyone but it
definitely won't be a big shocker if
this vampire monster mash mostly just
sucks
video game movies are on an upswing
based on the recent successes of pokemon
detective pikachu sonic the hedgehog and
mortal kombat is this a sign of a
reversing trend for video game movies
one of the most critically maligned and
commercially spurious of all movie
genres maybe but we're not betting on it
especially not for the first big screen
outing of nathan drake yes he's the main
protagonist of uncharted one of the best
selling most critically acclaimed video
game series ever but the key phrase here
is video game gamers like playing games
as nathan drake they don't necessarily
like buying a ticket to watch tom
holland play a young nathan drake while
tom holland may be a draw as spider-man
everybody is a draw as spider-man
outside the mcu holland hasn't shown his
medal and playing a square jawed
adventurer seems like a stretch for the
charmingly befuddled young brit still
we're always up for an old school
adventure we'll just probably be the
only people in the theater
marvel studios could probably release a
movie about dupe and it would still
gross a billion dollars meanwhile dc's
cinematic output has been a little more
hit or miss joker grossed a billion
dollars birds of prey not so much now dc
is taking a swing with dc league of
super pets scheduled for summer 2022 in
the animated film superman goes on
vacation so protecting the planet is
left to his dog crypto ace the bat hound
and a league of super pets crypto and
ace are voiced by dwayne johnson and
kevin hart stars of the rebooted jumanji
series they're joined by a stacked voice
cast including keanu reeves kate
mckinnon and john krasinski the lego
batman movie showed you can make a
popular family-friendly comedy spoofing
dc characters still this feels like a
charming hbo max series not a
blockbuster movie families will shell
out money for at least enough to justify
what we're sure is a budget pushing 100
million dollars if it's good it may make
money if it's so so it may end up being
more of a wait and stream thing if it's
bad well it wouldn't be the first dc
property to arrive to harsh criticism
i am not someone who is
loved
roland emmerich's stick of humans versus
world ending disaster used to be a
pretty reliable formula financially but
for more than a decade the biggest
disasters in emeric's filmography
haven't been on the screen but at the
box office he hasn't had a hit since
2009's 2012 which predicted the end of
the world but actually foretold the end
of his impressive run in between there
have been a few misbegotten attempts at
small-scale films like anonymous and
stonewall peppered with massive bombs
like independence day resurgence and
midway in our prediction look for
moonfall to continue the downward trend
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said as the title suggests
moonfall is about the moon getting
knocked out of its orbit and going on a
collision course with earth it stars
halle berry and patrick wilson talented
value adds in john wick and aquaman
movies but not reliable draws on their
own so with an eye-rolling concept and
unreliable box office draws moonfall has
a massive mountain to climb to earn a
profit on its reported 150 million
dollar budget maybe china will save the
day but domestically the only audience
for moonfall are dudes aged 18 to 34 who
were watching it ironically a prime demo
to be sure but not enough to save
moonfall from crashing to earth
nearly 20 years after its original
release shrek 2 remains one of the 15
biggest animated worldwide hits ever and
one of the top five of all time
domestically a big reason why was
antonio banderas turn as the
swashbuckling spaniard cat puss in boots
the character was so popular that he
even inspired his own spin-off which was
a big hit in 2011 grossing 149 million
dollars domestically and 554 million
dollars worldwide on a 130 million
dollar budget however 11 years will have
elapsed since the original puss in boots
and the magic number between sequels is
between two and four years any shorter
and you risk oversaturation any longer
and you risk the audience moving on the
latter is particularly a risk with
animated movies as the original audience
has literally grown up disney and pixar
can get away with it but we don't think
puss in boots has that sort of staying
power we're predicting the box office
for puss and boots the last wish will
stink worse than weak old kitty litter
one of the biggest casualties of the
kova 19 pandemic's effect on the film
industry may be top gun maverick which
is now set to arrive 36 years after the
release of the original movie originally
slated for release in the holiday season
of 2020 it's now set to take off finally
in september 2022 as far as release date
shuffling goes top gun maverick has been
moved around so much we feel like we're
sitting in the back of an f-16 fighter
jet hitting mach 2. is that disadvantage
made up by the combo of tom cruise and
nostalgia we doubt it cruz's four decade
movie star run is nearly unprecedented
in its level of success but lately he's
only been reliable in the mission
impossible movies maverick is one of his
most iconic characters but tom gunn is
memorable in a it was on tbs in the
afternoons kind of way not in a my
family watched it every year kind of way
there's a difference between genuine
nostalgia a la jurassic world and a
sequel to a popular movie from a bygone
era like independence day resurgence
decades later the world doesn't feel
like it was begging for a top gun sequel
in other words we just don't think
modern moviegoers still have the need
the need for speed
elle woods first sashayed her way onto
harvard law's campus for 2001's legally
blonde fresh-faced reese witherspoon
proved her box office bonafides with the
movie powering the 18 million dollar
film to a 141 million dollar worldwide
hall you don't need a high priced law
degree to know profit margins like that
are mighty impressive two years later
legally blonde 2 red white and blonde
brought l woods to washington dc and put
90 million dollars domestically and 125
million dollars into studio mgm's pocket
on a 25 million dollar budget legally
blonde 2 was slightly less successful
and that was the end of the story until
now mgm famously had monetary woes
throughout the 2000s which probably
contributed to putting off a timely
repeat in the meantime the legally
blonde brand expanded beyond the
multiplex to broadway so nearly 20 years
later does the moviegoing audience still
care about legally blonde a franchise
very much of its time we don't think so
while the plot is unknown elwood saga
succeeded because it was the ultimate
underdog story and we're not just
talking about her chihuahua we imagine
this movie will rely more on nostalgia
than on inspiring new audiences and in
today's movie landscape that just won't
be enough
what oh
have we passed peak sherlock holmes
maybe sir arthur conan doyle's world
famous sleuth first appeared in a study
in scarlet in 1887 and the character has
remained a figure in pop culture ever
since bbc's modern day sherlock series
brought benedict cumberbatch's
high-functioning sociopath homes to the
small screen and warner brothers
sherlock holmes films which turned
robert downey jr's homes and jude law's
john watson into victorian era action
heroes on the big screen both 2009's
sherlock holmes and 2011's sherlock
holmes a game of shadows made a pretty
penny earning 1 billion dollars
worldwide on a combined budget of 215
million dollars we imagine warner
brothers was begging for more sequels
but the avengers broke records in 2012
and downey went off to make another
million marvel movies you know give or
take so here we are more than a decade
later does anyone still care about
sherlock holmes the answer is elementary
no we already know that this particular
incarnation of sherlock holmes doesn't
have the staying power of an all-time
great franchise like star wars or toy
story when was the last time you even
thought about it our prediction this
will fall harder than sherlock off
reichenbach falls
this may be the pandora of all hot takes
after all avatar is the highest grossing
movie of all time with 2.8 billion
dollars worldwide based on pure math
alone even if avatar 2 dropped 50 it
would still be one of the highest
grossing movies ever with 1.4 billion
dollars even if it dropped 75
it'd still be flirting with 1 billion
dollars worldwide
this is why we're here that's the only
reason
it's what pays for the whole party given
china was still a small market when the
first film was released in 2009 and a
re-release in china is the main reason
avatar reclaimed its title from avengers
end game in 2020 are we crazy for
including it in our list of movies that
will bomb
maybe yet unlike star wars lord of the
rings or the matrix avatar didn't have
staying power sure everybody saw it in
2009 but only because we had to how many
kids dress up as na'vi for halloween
where are the avatar cartoons video
games and toys put simply who cares at
this point avatar 2 has been pushed back
6 times will come out 13 years after the
first and reportedly costs
250 million dollars avatar 2 may make
money but it's hard to see how its box
office could be anything but a pale
imitation of its predecessor and
depending on how people react to it it
may pave the way for three more box
office disasters in the series future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]